[Musique]
bonjour Pascal Alisa merci beaucoup
d'être notre invité vous êtes élu du
Calvados membre du groupe les
républicains vice-président de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armé du Sénat et
on va évidemment longuement revenir avec
vous sur ce déplacement d'Emmanuel
Macron hier au Proche Orient il était en
Israël il a ensuite renconté Mahmoud
Abbas le Palestinien il est aujourd'hui
en Jordanie est-ce qu'il a fait ce qu'il
fallait faire je pense que ce
déplacement était nécessaire et qu'il
intervient à un bon moment du calendrier
donc effectivement c'est une excellente
initiative qu'on ne peut que soutenir il
a bien fait d'attendre c'est ce que vous
dites parce que certain certains
critiquai y compris dans votre camp le
fait qu'il y soit allé trop tard oui
mais moi je trouve qu'il y est allé au
bon moment en fait voilà et je tiens à
le dire c'est-à-dire qu'il ça a permis
de parler à tout le monde ce qu'il
n'aurait pas pu faire s'il était allé il
faut parler à tout le monde je crois que
c'est d'abord une crise comme celle-là
nécessite que l'on parle à tout le monde
et la vocation de la diplomatie
française
et du président de la République
française quel qu'il soit c'est de
parler à tout le monde donc je je
soutiens cette démarche absolument
Emmanuel Macron qui voulait que sa
visite soit utile est-ce que pour vous
elle a été utile cette visite écoutez
dans les rencontres qu'il a pu avoir ça
a été l'occasion de réaffirmer bien
évidemment l'horreur de ce qui s'est
passé et et toute la condamnation que
l'on peut y apporter il y a aucune
ambiguité sur le sujet c'est aussi
l'occasion de rappeler qu' sera
a le droit de se défendre il y a quand
même un agresseur et un agressé Israël a
le droit de se défendre mais notre
devoir c'est aussi de rappeler à Israël
que cela doit se faire dans le respect
bah du droit international et du droit
humanitaire notamment et là je crois que
le président a eu aussi les mots qu'il
fallait vous craigz que ce ne soit pas
le cas qu'Israël aille trop loin alors
c'est un petit peu le le danger mais on
voit quand même que pour le moment les
ordres ne sont pas donnés pour rentrer
dans dans Gaza et et je pense qu'il faut
effectivement temporiser sur ce point
probablement faire la part des choses
d'ailleurs entre la Palestine et le
Hamas c'est un point qu'on peut
peut-être revoir dans quelques instants
et je ne suis pas certain que les
populations civiles palestiniennes
méritent méritent ce qui ce qui pourrait
se passer en cas de de d'entrée des des
forces de tsal dans dans la bande de
Gaza et par ailleurs d'un point de vue
strictement militaire on peut aussi
s'interroger sur la capacité israélienne
même avec les alliés américains de la
réussite d'une telle opération et de sa
réussite dans la durée je pense qu'on
risquerait plutôt un embrasement général
et vous pensez qu'Israël n'arrivera pas
à anéantir le Hamas puisque c'est son
but je pense qu'Israël aura des
résultats mais anéantir totalement le le
Hamas une opération comme celle-là me
semble moi peu probable et qu'ils
n'arriveront pas à le faire rapidement
c'est aussi la question vous craignez
que ça dure c'est ce qu'on peut craindre
aussi les opérations de Guera urbaine
ont toujours montré qu'elles étaient
complexes et qu'elles étaient coûteus il
n'est pas certain que les opinions
publiques malgré ce qui s'est passé
l'acceptent Emmanuel Macron qui est allé
plaider pour relancer le processus de
paix pour une solution à deux états
est-ce que cette solution elle est
possible en ce moment est-ce que c'est
le moment du dialogue alors dans ce
genre de situation je crois qu'il faut
toujours avoir en tête le jour d'après
quand même et effectivement ce jour
d'après passe par une solution à deux
états euh je crois que là il y a une
certaine unanimité qui est en train de
se faire à la fois dans le camp
occidental mais mais aussi y compris
dans les débats entre nous au niveau au
niveau français euh on on n' pas le
droit de priver plus longtemps les
Palestiniens de leur état parce que
c'est quand même une une situation qui
dure depuis des des dizaines d'années
donc il faut travailler à cette
situation à deux états avec une capitale
à Jérusalem est tel que ça a été
envisagé et faire en sorte que un peu
dans la logique d'ailleurs des accords
d'Abraham on arrive à trouver au bout du
bout un équilibre mais mais c'est est-ce
que c'est le moment vous entendez les
déclarations des dirigeants israéliens
Palestiniens benamine meanou il veut
venger Israël Marmoud Abbas il accuse
Israël de tuer des innocents à Gaza
est-ce qu'avec de telles déclarations on
peut entamer un dialogue bien je crois
que ces déclarations elles sont
finalement assez légitimes contte tenu
de ce qui s'est passé on ne peut pas
dire qu'Israël ne porte aucune
responsabilité dans la situation
actuelle et à forceori les Palestiniens
en tout cas les membres du Hamas portent
une lourde responsabilité dans dans dans
la situation donc à un moment donné il
faut effectivement que tout cela
s'exprime que les choses soient dites
mais l'intérêt aussi d'avoir ce genre de
débat avec des Alli avec des partenaires
internationaux c'est qu'on peut aussi
jouer un petit peu les modérateurs et et
ouvrir des pistes pour le futur c'est
aussi là la responsabilité de la France
et c'est son rôle est-ce que la France
elle est en capacité d'obtenir un cess
le feu est-ce qu'elle est une clé en
tout cas pour l'obtenir je pense que les
les relations que nous pouvons avoir
avec les différentes puissances
régionales doivent nous permettre
effectivement avec d'autres d'avancer
dans cette recherche de de de de de
solution je crois aussi que cette crise
que finalement personne n'avait vraiment
venu venir c'est un peu un impensé
stratégique israélien quand même il il y
a un vrai sujet sur ce qui s'est passé
c'est peut-être aussi l'occasion de
reconstruire une politique arabe
française et pas seulement de se
contener à faire de la gestion de crise
et c'est possible ça aujourd'hui on a vu
les réactions dans certains pays arabes
anti-française clairement mais
antirrançaise clairement parce qu'il
faut que la France se repos ine sur une
vraie politique Arab et pas seulement
une politique suiveuse des États-Unis je
crois que là il y a un point important
j'ai rien contre les États-Unis mais la
France est une puissance qui doit
réaffirmer ses ses principes avec une
vraie politique arabe et c'est peut-être
là où je suis un peu plus modéré par
rapport à la position du président de la
République je suis pas certain qu'il
faille confondre les coalitions et les
coalitions antidaesh anti-état islamique
c'est une chose elles ont leur raison
d'être mais globaliser sur le sujet avec
le Hamas n'est pas à mon avis une bonne
idée par on va parler tout de suite de
cette coalition un dernier mot euh juste
est-ce que Emmanuel Macron fait entendre
une voix là où la communauté
internationale a failli selon
vous écoutez oui il fait entendre la
voix de la France c'est toujours une
c'est toujours une bonne chose
euh est-ce qu'on sera écouté on verra au
au résultats et pour qu'il y ait des
résultats il faut qu'il y ait des
efforts dans dans la la durée on va
venir sur cette coalition c'était
effectivement l'une des phrases
importantes hier du déplacement
d'Emmanuel Macron mais d'abord on va
parler de ce qui s'est passé hier au
Sénat il en a également été question
après l'assemblée lundi Elisabeth borne
était donc devant les sénateurs hier
après-midi pour un débat sur la
situation au Proche Orient on va voir
les temps forts de ce qui s'est passé
avec Steve
[Musique]
jourin bonjour bonjouronjour monsieur le
sénateur Steve hier était donc organisé
au Sénat un débat sur la situation au
Proche Orient oui un débat organisé au
titre de l'article 50-1 de la
Constitution on dit débat mais il
s'agissait en fait bien d'une succession
de déclaration le gouvernement a décidé
de ne pas procéder à un vote comme le
touris pourtant la Constitution il
aurait aussi pu mettre à l'ordre du du
jour une résolution qui avait été
déposée par la majorité sénatoriale et
qui visait à exprimer la la solidarité
de la France avec l'État d'Israël le
gouvernement a refusé de l'inscrire à
l'ordre du jour Marseille le regrette
écoutez-le nous avons été étonnés de
d'observer que cette résolution n'avait
pas été inscrite à l'ordre du jour par
le gouvernement que nous n'avions pas
été prévenu en tous les cas moi j'ai pas
été prévenu en tant que signataire ce
que j'aurais aimé être et ce qui marque
quand même une certaine réserve
vis-à-vis du du Parlement et chaque
groupe politique a donc eu l'occasion
hier d'afficher sa position sur les
événements en cours entre Israël et le
oui il y avait pas beaucoup de suspense
he chaque groupe chaque parti avait déjà
eu l'occasion de s'exprimer très
largement sur le sujet depuis les
attaques du 7 octobre on se demandait si
les polémique autour des déclarations de
la France insoumise qui refuse et bien
de qualifier le le Hamas d'organisation
terroriste aller s'inviter au Sénat la
réponse est oui
écoutez ceux qui confondent le droit du
peuple palestinien à disposer d'un état
et la justification du terrorisme
commettent une faute morale politique et
stratégieque
je voudrais simplement rappeler à tous
les islamo gauchistes qui se déshonorent
en refusant de qualifier en refusant de
qualifier de
terroriste les crimes qui ont été commis
le Hamas c'est pas un mouvement de
libération c'est un acronyme qui
signifie d'ailleurs mouvement de
résistance islamique l'inspirateur qui
n'est plus le le CH tiassine son crédau
ça n'est pas de libérer la Palestine son
crédau c'était de soumettre la Palestine
à la charia et justement à gauche St
est-ce qu'il y a eu des voix
discordantes qu'on a pu voir au sein de
l' nuup comme à l'Assemblée nationale
non pas vraiment socialistes communistes
et écologistes ont tenu plus ou moins la
même ligne condamnation du terrorisme du
Hamas et rappel de la nécessité d'une
paix au Proche Orient écoutez le 7
octobre dernier le Hamas a frappé Israël
et son peuple avec une violence abjecte
lors de cet attentat terroriste plus de
1400 personnes ont été massacrées plus
de 3000 ont été blessés avec une
barbarie qui a choqué les esprits et
révulsé les cœurs aux quatre coins du
monde ces monstruosités constittuent les
pires horreurs que le monde est connu
depuis les années 1990 durant lesquelles
EUR lieu le génocide randais ou le
massacre de seranit ici c'est l'acte
génocidaire le plus important contre le
peuple juif depuis la choie et le temps
des poromes la France doit au-delà des
mots réellement s'attaquer au Hamas je
le redis le Hamas ne peut pas être pour
les progressistes que nous sommes
l'avenir du peuple palestinien la
barbarie du 7 octobre dernier le
démontre aux yeux du monde entier ces
liens avec le djihad islamiste et
d'autres le placent factuellement dans
le camp des ennemis de la liberté
monieur le sénateur il y a donc eu ce
débat plutôt cette succession de de
déclaration vous regrettez qu'il n'y ait
pas eu cette résolution qui aurait
permis un vote des sénateurs sur le
sujet oui je pense que on a raté une
occasion
le gouvernement a raté une occasion d'un
moment d'unité nationale encore un petit
peu plus fort parce que à la lumière des
interventions vous venez d'en montrer
certaines il y a eu un un moment d'unité
effectivement sur ce sujet et on aurait
eu un vote peut-être pas unanime mais en
tout cas très très très majoritaire et
au-delà du clivage des groupes
politiques et je crois que ça aurait pu
renforcer la position française et aussi
par contraste par rapport à qui a pu se
passer à l'Assemblée nationale je crois
que ça aurait été une bonne chose un bon
signal vous saluez cette ces positions
de la gauche au Sénat qui ont montré une
certaine unité dans cette histoire
notamment par rapport à ce qui s'est
passé à l'Assemblée nationale mais mais
mais mais absolument vous entendez les
mots de Bruno retaillot vous entendez
madame borne et vous entendez les propos
de la présidente Cécile cuckerman chacun
à leur façon chacun avec leur mots
finalement font la même condamnation on
va parler de cette coalition puisque
c'est c'est c'est l'une des phrases VO
la phrase qu'il faut retenir du
déplacement d'Emmanuel Macron hier il
veut que la coalition internationale
contre daesh puisse aussi lutter contre
le Hamas est-ce que c'est une bonne idée
pour
vous créer une coalition sur ce sujet
indiscutablement est une bonne idée
faut-il joindre les deux coalitions je
n'en suis absolument pas
convaincu nous sommes sur la
problématique daesh état islamique déjà
sur des sujets un petit peu plus anciens
et sur des développements qui ne sont
pas du tout similaires nous avons sur
cette coalition des partenaires arabes
et il faut absolument conserver ces
partenariats et par rapport à la
situation spécifique
israël-pestine prenons garde de ne pas
nous couper de ces soutiens des pays
arabes qui sont c'est le risque
absolument c'est pour ça que je suis
assez réservé sur cette proposition
juste qu'on comprenne bien vous saluer
cette idée de de coalition mais ça
voudrait dire qu'on pourrait imaginer
des avions français bombardés à Gaza
écoutez je crois qu'on en est pas encore
là l'objectif de la coalition c'est
aussi de faire monter la pression et
peut-être de faire comprendre au Hamas
et à ses dirigeants qu'il va arriver à
un moment où tout ça ne sera plus
possibleivez pas c'est pas quelque chose
vous dites qu'on'est pas encore là mais
pour en arriver là ça peut en arriver là
ou alors si d'embla on annonce qu'on en
arrivera pas là ça sert à rien c'est
faire des moulinets avec un Sabr en bois
sinon est-ce que vous souhaitez des des
précisions sur ce que Emmanuel Macron
veut mettre derrière ce mot coalition
est-ce que pour vous il faut des
explications devant le Parlement je
pense que c'est une solution à
construire une fois de plus ne
mélangeons pas les deux coalitions ça je
crois qu'il faut il faut se tenir à ça
et effectivement construire une solution
collective avec les États-Unis et une
fois de plus sans se couper de nos
partenaires arabes il y a 30 morts
compté français vous trouvez qu'on en
parle assez de ces morts français
non non je trouve que on n parle pas
suffisant alors effectivement il y a
1400 1500 mors soueriez une journée
dommage oui alors est-ce qu'il faut une
journée d'mage bon mais mais mais mais
mais je pense
qu'effectivement c'est aussi un danger
de ce conflit c'est son importation sur
le territoire national et et là je
trouve qu'on n fait pas assez sur la
question pour éviter l'importation oui
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait faire de
plus je trouve que les les mesures de
sécurité
prises sont pas voyantes me semble
insuffisant et et et finalement peu
rassurante si vous demandez quoi la mise
en place de l'état d'urgence on peut en
arriver là on peut l'envisager oui même
si parce que le gouvernement dit que les
mesures qui lui sont nécessaires sont
désormais dans la loi ordinaire et qu'il
y a pas besoin de l'état d'urgence oui
ouiou on l'entend on l'entend mais c'est
pas votre une situation d'exception
pourrait marquer les choses de manière
un peu plus claire le le Qatar pay ami
de la France historique il finance le
pays finance le le Hamas à hauteur de 30
millions de dollars par par mois est-ce
que c'est tenable cette position est
tenable est-ce qu'il faut rompre nos
liens avec le Qatar non assurément il
faut pas rompre les liens avec le Qatar
le Qatar est partie prenante des
négociations et actuellement fait un
travail d'intermédiaire entre les
différentes parties c'est toute la
difficulté de ce genre de
situation le le le le le le Qatar
discute avec un certain nombre de
partenaires
différents sur le financement du Hamas
on le sait alors on nous explique que
c'est le le le volet culturel le volet
éducation mais c'est ce qui fait aussi
que le Hamas aujourd'hui contrôle Gaza
c'est c'est tout ce travail qui n'a pas
été fait par d'autres partenaires je
dire depuis ces élections ces élections
de 2005 ou 6 où
finalement le le Hamas a surplanté le
fata dans dans les élection euh les
choses se sont figées il y a aussi une
guerre civile entre eux on a une
situation assez terrible parce que la
Palestine on en parle comme si c'était
une unité c'est tout sauf une unité moi
je je travaille à l'os à l'Assemblée
parlementaire où je suis Représentant
spécial pour la Méditerranée j'ai eu
jusqu'à 2020 des échanges réguliers avec
des collègues du Conseil national
palestinien et des parlementaires
israéliens on se rencontrait ensemble on
se parlerit ensemble tout ça aujourd'hui
c'est terminé et ça conduit à ce genre
de situation sur le Qatar qui abrite le
chef du Hamas le Qatar est-ce qu'
aujourd'hui c'est le problème ou la
solution
mais je pense que ça peut être la
solution parce qu'il va bien falloir
rétablir le dialogue donc ne nous
coupons pas du
Qatar ça peut paraître paradoxal mais
c'est ainsi un mot peut-être sur sur
l'Iran et plus qu'un mot l'Iran qui
alerte les États-Unis qui alerte Israël
sur le fait que la situation pourrait
devenir incontrôlable manuel Macron qui
met en garde l'Iran contre toute
escalade ou extension du conflit
notamment au Liban c'est à redouter pour
vous oui c'est
certainement la position de l'Iran on a
absolument aucune preuve à ma
connaissance du comportement de l'Iran
sur les événements du 7 bon que que
l'Iran soit un acteur important dans ce
secteur personne ne le conteste sur les
événements du
se soit impliqué directement cela étant
il faut être extrêmement prudent parce
que que on ne peut pas prendre le risque
d'un
embrasement généralisé dans ce secteur
là et l'Iran je vis quand même préciser
qu'on parle d'un secteur arabe mais ce
sont des Perses et ils ont pas toujours
le même raisonnement que les autres on
peut penser d'ailleurs de manière un peu
cynique mais ils le sont aussi que voir
des puissances arabes s'affaiblir entre
elles ça fait aussi leurs affaires donc
voyez les choses sont pas aussi
contrastées qu'on veut bien le dire mais
prendre le danger d'un embrasement et
d'une entrée de l'Iran dans le conflit
il faut absolument absolument l'éviter
estce que l'Iran n'est pas déjà dans le
conflit le hzbollah lance des roquett de
manière quotidienne sur Israël le
Hezbolah qui est l'allié le proxyou
c'est le proxy bien sûr c'est le proxy
donc l'Iran est certaine manière déjà
impliqué et qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
qu'est-ce que la France peut faire dans
cette histoire est-ce que la France peut
parler au hzbola est-ce que la France
doit s'adresser directement à l'Iran
est-ce qu'on le fait déjà à votre
connaissance écoutez je crois qu'il faut
parler avec les IR
quels seront les résultats mais il faut
parler aussi avec eux et il faut en tout
cas faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait pas
d'escalade or là aussi pour qu'il n'y
ait pas d'escalade il faut parler avec
les Iraniens il faut faire en sorte
qu'il ne rentre pas plus en avant dans
cette démarche après on n'est pas naïf
on sait très bien le comportement qu'ils
peuvent avoir localement merci Steve à
tout à l'heure vous reviendrez
évidemment longuement dans le club pour
on reparlera avec vous de cette
situation on va aller voir l'actualité
dans votre département maintenant pas
qu'Al la lzard on va à cand on retrouve
Léa quignot bonjour Léa merci d'être là
vous êtes journaliste chef d'édition à
Tendance Ouest on parle d'un tout autre
sujet avec vous Léa on parle de la
précarité
étudiante oui bonjour auien
effectivement c'est un sujet préoccupant
pour tous les les étudiants français
mais aussi normand ils y échappent pas
euh cette précarité étudiante qui chaque
année augmente les étudiants euh à
l'université de camp par exemple ça
coûte 2900 € cette rentrée pour un
étudiant c'est 3 % de plus que l'an
dernier alors que déjà en 2022 ce coût
de la rentrée avait augmenté alors cela
comprend tout un tas de dépenses la
première c'est la la le transport
ensuite le logement pardon ensuite le
transport les frais de scolarité et puis
l'alimentation au niveau national un
chiffre important c'est près de la
moitié des étudiants qui déclarent
sauter au moins un repas par jour c'est
assez impressionnant et parmi eux 16 %
le font pour des raisons financières on
peut penser donc avec l'inflation la
situation s'aggrave déjà et risque de
s'aggraver dans les années à venir ou
dans les mois à venir quels sont les ha
quels sont les pistes les initiatives
les solutions pour répondre à cette
situation et bien oui il en existe
plusieurs en tout cas je pense notamment
au au logement cru au repas
universitaire à 1 € pour les les
boursiers mais ça ne suffit pas et donc
les les étudiants se mobilisent
eux-mêmes pour rendre service à leur pèr
à le aux étudiants eux-mêmes et par
exemple à quand il y a une épicerie
solidaire qui existe depuis 2004 14 qui
s'appelle la gorae alors c'est pas un
cas unique à c ça existe dans plusieurs
plusieurs universités françaises c'est
une une épisserie qui permet aux
étudiants de se nourrir à moindre coût
c'est-à-dire à 10 % du prix du marché
370 étudiants canné en ont bénéficier
l'an dernier un record et cette année
j'en discutais avec des bénévoles il y a
pas plus de 2 jours c'est déjà 115
étudiants qui sont inscrits alors ils
sont dans des situations diverses des
situations critiques il y en a certains
qui qui n'ont plus que 5 € pour vivre
par mois d'autres qui n'ont pas le choix
de faire des pré-étudiants pour se
nourrir et puis le travail un étudiant
sur deux à quand doit cumuler un job
étudiant avec avec l'université avec
leurs études cela a de quoi inquiéter he
pour la réussite de leur scolarité alors
j'imagine que Pascal elzard vous suivez
ce ce ce dossier de près j'ai une
question pour vous les associations
étudiantes canais aujourd'hui suggèrent
une réforme de des bourses est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous leur répondez est-ce
que c'est possible ça aujourd'hui bien
écoutez tout tout d'abord vous dire que
c'est une situation que je connais un
petit peu parce que je m'étais déplacé
sur le campus il y a 2 ans sur ce
sujet-là voilà donc j'avais passé pas
mal de temps sur le terrain avec les
étudiants pour en parler et et je
partage votre analyse effectivement avec
l'inflation et avec la crise qui
malheureusement prospère la situation
s'est fortement dégradée j'avais à
l'époque d'ailleurs fait une question
écrite au ministre qui avait annoncé un
certain nombre de mesures vous venez de
de de de de les rappeler et je crois que
c'était une bonne chose et et il faut
aller au-delà moi ce que je vais vous
répondre c'est que je vais reprendre mon
bâton de pèlerin je vais retourner à
leur rencontre sur le campus à camp pour
en discuter avec eux je suis très
attaché à cette université c'est là où
j'ai fait mes études il y a déjà
quelques années et j'y suis resté
extrêmement attaché et effectivement
s'il faut euh engager des démarches
vis-à-vis du gouvernement pour modifier
le système de bourse et le faire évoluer
on le
demandera merci à vous merci Léa merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous Léa
quignot journaliste chef d'édition à
Tendance Ouest merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous Léa un dernier mot sur un
autre sujet c'est la loi immigration qui
arrive au Sénat dans une dizaine de
jours maintenant sur votre ligne rouge
l'article 3 la ligne rouge des
républicains sur la régularisation dans
les métiers en tension le Parisien
évoque un dîner entre ellisabeth borne
et Bruno ill au cours duquel la première
ministre s'est dit ouverte à retiré cet
article est-ce que Bruno rotaillot vous
l'a confirmé écoutez je ne vais ni
confirmer ni affirmer parce que je ne le
sais pas
euh la configuration je crois du
Parlement aujourd'hui fait que ce texte
va nous amener forcément là aussi à nous
parler et à faire en sorte de nous
entendre sinon il ne se passera pas
grand-chose donc c'est-à-dire qu'il faut
trouver un compromis coûte que coûte je
crois qu'il faut trouver un accord dans
l'intérêt du pays sur cet article y
compris il faut pas en faire une ligne
rouge absolue de cet article bien non
sinon la position du Sénat ne sera pas
entendue c'est pas notre façon de
travailler et si c'est pour que ça se
termine au 493 à l'Assemblée nationale
sur un mauvais compromis je crois que ce
serait la pire des solutions et ça ce
n'est que mon avis c'est votre avis on a
bien compris c'est c'est c'est pas
l'avis officiel de votre groupe pour
vous ça doit pas être une ligne rouge je
pense qu'à un moment donné il va bien
falloir trouver un accord avec le le le
gouvernement et je crois que le gouver
gouvernement a quand même tout à fait
intérêt à se rapprocher de nous plutôt
que l'inverse qu'il fait Gérald haranin
il a dit qu'il était prêt à soutenir la
quasi totalité de vos propositions dans
le Journal du Dimanche dimanche il a
même dit que cet article 3 n'était
peut-être pas central mais se rapproche
suffisamment absolument mais je crois
que Gérald daranin progresse énormément
et et on en est très content pour lui ce
qui nous intéresse c'est quand même la
vie de l'Élysée et et de matigon vous
craignez queabeth Emmanuel Macron
n'aille pas dans le même sens que lui on
verra on verra tout dépend là vous savez
ce texte ça va être un vrai test
politique au sens vraiment politique du
terme sur la capacité à la fois du
gouvernement de l'Assemblée nationale
dans sa configuration 2022 et du Sénat
dans cette nouvelle configuration de de
sortir un texte dans l'intérêt des
Français le le le le c'est vraiment je
crois un vrai examen que nous allons les
uns et les autres subir sur ce texte- là
et et dont le résultat va conditionner
je crois beaucoup de beaucoup de vote
ultérieur et beaucoup de comportements
ultérieurs c'est-à-dire la capacité des
LR à s'entendre avec le gouvernement
ou pas du tout donc c'est soit le
rapprochement soit la
rupture ça peut arriver oui absolument
merci Pascal Alizard merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous d'avoir été notre
invité ce matin